you can see what I've got here I think
pretty sure isn't like a cliche trip if
I'm wrong okay I have all the different
kinds of sample means listen on the
vertical axis right you can see my range
is from one and a half just five and a
half one knots the lower second possible
yet because there's our smallest two
number two my population
five-and-a-half is the biggest for the
reverse reason okay and there's the
distribution and one of the lovely
things happens is we just turn your head
a little bit surprise surprise the
normal distribution because that's
exactly what you get whenever you look
at a population and there's some element
of randomness so the last thing we now
want to work out is if the most amount
of work mathematically you have to do is
now I want to work out I just have
enough space to squeeze into many people
you've worked out number one all the
samples number two you've worked out the
means for all the samples the sample is
okay number three you now have a picture
of what they look like what the
distribution is okay fourth and last and
it is going to sound confusing we now
want to work out the mean of the sample
means we said it again okay you have a
whole bunch of simple we know
represented over here I want to find the
mean of all 15 of them okay if you have
15 scores of any kind how do you work
out their mean yeah very good
if you have 15 tours you add up to 15
tours and then you design by 15 okay
then you can really quickly office you
have to do it 15 times you can then
double-ups all the way right so have a
look you can see are then five and a
half we mentioned that one that only
happens once
then there's fine but then when you get
to four and a half it happens twice so
if I'm going to say I'll do four a half
twice and I'll do four how it goes look
also times in bar calculator quickly
there is one and only one mean that
happens three times which
is so I'm going to multiply that 1 by 3
and then I'm going to keep going on this
is my way of adding up all the meat that
make sense so I'll finish off whatever
now I've added up all 15 by the time I
hit equals on the calculator there but I
want not the sum of all those I want the
average to be enormous so what I'm going
to do is keep don't forget it's the
whole thing the Sun right there you go
ok so go ahead I just wanted you to make
sure now remember it's largely the same
we're going to get color on 11 X
remember we observed when we turned our
head sideways oh this is this is a
normal distribution
Enza the normal distribution I want you
to think all they've acted a star ds5 I
introduced the normal distribution and I
said it had a bunch of characteristics
do you remember what the characteristics
were snowman easy remember it's on a
heart I chose you and straight to the
hard one well the one that's relevant to
a good job ok we said this the normal
distribution number 1 is symmetrical
okay number 2 it's got that bell kind of
curve shape right but one of the things
which is not mentioned frequently is on
a perfect normal distribution the mean
and the mode and the median are all in
the same value right and you guys can
all see this is obviously the boat look
it happened too much frequently right
why is it the median like the median
look it's bang it's wide open in the
middle right which means that even
without computing because the perfect
normal distribution you can do the main
murder meaning of all three and a half